make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin all right what's going on
guys this is rob and we are picking back
up again with dark knight's metal but
this time we're covering the lobo
one shot and anybody who knows anything
about dc comics knows that lobo is the
most 1990s character ever and this story
i'm not gonna lie to you guys this story
is a descent into absolute
madness this initially picks up in a bar
right just kind of six months ago right
before seemingly all this this or at
least when this dark knights metal stuff
kind of kicked off right so
uh following perpetuous takeover is
basically when this happens and
uh we initially pick up with lobo in the
spark and of course getting pissed off
for the bartender because the bartender
is not getting him any more drinks only
for us to find out the reason why the
bartender can't get him more drinks is
because he ripped off the bartender's
arms and beat everybody in the bar to
death with them and so that's why the
bartender can't get him any drinks
so the other part of that is that he was
here originally for the bounty but he
killed the guy in the bar before anybody
could tell him or before he could tell
lobo who he actually was or
and basically beat everybody to death
before they could tell him who he was so
lobo basically went into a rage which is
kind of normal right that's what lobo
does right when you're basically a
parody of wolverine that's essentially
what you do you just go into arbitrary
rages for the reasons it don't really
make any sense because you know that's
what wolverine does and he grabs the
body and of course he ends up being kind
of yanked away now when he janked away
he's basically pulled
by what looks like a version of lobo
right like this just huge
gaudy version of lobo this guy is
technically he's he's like the
the what is it the batman who frags
that's a stupid name we should call him
batlobo right that's a much better name
right so like we're gonna call him bat
lobo
like batman becomes lobo that's
basically what we're gonna call him but
essentially it's one of the craziest
things because as soon as lobo goes to
punch this guy he immediately gets the
upper hand takes lobo down and that's it
now one thing to understand about this
guy about lobo's character this is a guy
that can go toe-to-toe with superman
this guy is not someone to be scoffed at
but he's not some kind of small time guy
the other thing about this
is that batman becoming lobo basically
happened in a dark
dark universe somewhere in the dark
multiverse where bruce wayne injected
himself
with zarnian dna and it essentially gave
him all the strength and the healing
factor of lobo
combined with all the skills and the
fighting powers of batman so like
literally he's able to take on lobo
quite readily right i mean just
able to to get the upper hand on this
guy quick fast and in a hurry and the
fight's not much of a big long drawn out
fight
one of the other things that happens is
that where he's he's fighting off
against lobo we end up finding out that
lobo
is actually playing possum right he's
just kind of faking how weak he is and
that's one of the crazy things that goes
on here is because in this batman who
frags right this bat lobos reality we
don't really know if lobo in the
traditional sense
ever actually existed right it's just
zarni and dna we don't really know if
that's the case i mean presumably it is
right because he got the dna from
somewhere but lobo actually ends up
grabbing his own you know batarang chain
thing and
throws it in his stomach and then
suddenly lobos
like to yank away yet again right he
snatched away again and when that
happens of course he arrives in front of
lex luthor now this kind of explains on
the back end
how it is that during the events of dark
knight's medal so basically the first
you know four issues that we've covered
so far
why is it lobos on some kind of a
special quest we didn't really know what
was going on
right we just kind of got these cutaways
where we'd show lobo just doing a thing
and we wouldn't really get a whole lot
of explanation we knew that he was
communicating with lex luthor and
whatever
his whatever his mission was had to do
with something lex luthor sent him for
but we didn't really know anything
besides that
right so it's cool for us to get this
kind of explanation here well the
reality is that lobo has been sent on a
mission by lex luthor
to basically capture what's called death
metal and death metal this actual
material here is essentially a material
that can rewrite
all of reality but this is one of the
issues that i'm sort of having with with
dark knight's metal dark knight's metal
is a fun story it's a good event but it
kind of feels like things are just being
invented
out of thin air for the sake of telling
a story right just kind of being
invented on the fly right just like
moment like this it's not really planned
out it's just kind of just things being
being invented out of nowhere like a lot
of the stuff just kind of feels too
convenient if that makes any sense but
the other part of this is that it is
called death metal right so it makes
sense that there would be some kind of
material
out there called death metal that would
have the power to rewrite and recreate
all of reality
as the wielder sees fit right to
basically recreate it all right and
that's what's kind of nuts here is
something that you don't usually see in
dc comics which i think is what's really
kind of getting to me that's something
that you see in marvel all the time
right the infinity gaunt
infinity gauntlet the cosmic cube the
cosmic regulator you see it all the time
when like somebody achieves a level of
power or they have the ability to
recreate all of reality on a whim right
i mean
and not even just the universe the whole
multiverse sometimes i'm not really used
to seeing that in dc
comics somebody attaining an artifact
that makes them so incredibly powerful
they can control and manipulate
the entirety of the multiverse itself
now again i'm not nearly as well versed
in dc comics as i am in marvel when it
comes to like a lot of the more obscure
nitty-gritty things stuff like that
because outside of the infinity gauntlet
if i walk up to the average person on
the street and i say hey what's the
casket of ancient winters or what is the
heart of the universe they're not going
to be able to give me an answer because
they're not going to know well that's
not something that they're familiar with
and so i'm
you know with with dc i'm not nearly as
well versed in their intricate artifacts
as i am with marvel but i'm not aware of
anything that's that powerful
in dc so it feels wholly new but in
order to go on this mission lobos like i
need some kind of transportation and
that's when one's basically given to him
by lex luthor right like
his space bike and so as soon as he gets
his space bike he basically takes off
only for us to find out that
uh that the batman i guess the the
batman who frags right is still very
much awake and is basically
on the on the mission or going on the
mission of tracking down
lobo now at this point we switch over to
what's technically the second part and
the reason why this matters is because
this lobo comic is not written by one
person
so you've got frank thierry who's
writing this first part you've got becky
cloonan who writes the last part of the
second part and then you got sam
humphries who writes the third part but
neither one of these parts are
exceedingly long
right instead there may be nine or ten
pages each and so we switch over to uh
to the second part here and we've got
lobo on black hawk island out in the
middle of nowhere if you guys recall
black hawk island is where the the
original dark knights metal event
all kind of kicked off in terms of the
realization that like everything's sort
of popping off so it's kind of cool to
see us return to this familiar place but
in the middle of that
lobo ends up facing off against what
looks i mean technically he's called
black monday but it's like solomon
grundy batman
so uh in any event one of the things to
kind of keep in mind when it comes to
lobo
is that he is kind of an idiot and he's
easy to manipulate in a lot of different
ways and that's one of the things that
lobo says right level kind of builds on
him and it's just kind of like
you know you're basically a goof right i
mean you're an evil batman right so
you're not necessarily
weak but like think about it right they
put you on this island by yourself to
keep an eye out for anybody who stumbles
along
they put you here because nobody likes
you and you don't have any friends
nobody wants to be your friend and in
fact lobo almost kind of starts
befriending
solomon grundy when he's like we're
actually not that different you and i
right like i don't really have any
friends now the reason why lobo has no
friends is because he killed everybody
on his home planet killed and killed his
entire race and uh is basically a bounty
hunter who's just kind of a dick
nonetheless you know that's kind of why
he doesn't have any friends ah just
something to keep in mind guys if you
want friends
don't be a dick nobody wants to be
friends with a dick unless
well there is that one guy every circle
of friends has that one guy who is kind
of a dick but he's ours right he's our
friend right he's allowed to be that be
that guy
because he's our friend right and how to
get away with murder
it's asher that guy's hilarious i love
that show
uh i don't know why i started talking
about that in any event
getting back on track you end up having
lobo and you end up having you know
solomon grundy or at least solomon
granny kind of defeated
and then from there uh he ends up
traveling through this this place with
all these different artifacts
and uh ends up finding a box that's
supposed to contain the death metal
right and he's like man like it can't
just simply be lying around like this
you know and he's like okay so like when
he finds it it's simply not there and
that's what hawkman shows up he's like
you really don't think that i would have
taken this artifact that had the ability
to rewrite all of reality and just left
it sitting in a room somewhere
right i mean no it doesn't work that way
it's a terrible idea to do that instead
uh he had various notebooks all the
notes that he'd taken since the dawn of
time if you guys remember
the adventures of of carter hall from
dark knight's medal when he was thrust
back to the very beginning of time and
basically started writing through
all these different these different
notes and everything that he knew about
the events of enth metal and all that
kind of stuff
he'd been basically documenting
everything that he knew about death
metal as well
and then in turn all those different
notebooks were stolen but what he did
is he managed to hide the the death
metal itself right he managed to keep it
hidden away in a place where nobody
would be able to find it except for
carter hall himself and so when he's
talking to lobo
initially he doesn't want to hand it
over he doesn't want to give it to lobo
but lobo actually makes this
really really cool this really cool
argument here what he basically says
is that he's not really here because
he's tempted by the power of death metal
and he wants to use it for his own
ends that's not why he's looking to
attain it he's looking to attain it
because it's a mission he was sent on
right he's just doing it for the bounty
and that's kind of an interesting thing
one of the funny things about lobo is
that he's not really a guy
who focuses on trying to attain absolute
power
right he just cares about the cash right
cash money right moolah
cheddar that's all he really cares about
right just just just cheese that's all
he cares about is just getting cheese
i don't know if people use that phrase
anymore what phrase do you guys use
in relation to like money right like
getting stacks
right i don't know what phrase you guys
use anymore mariah says it's called
stacking your coins is that true
because if it is it's like the least
cool thing ever right like yeah man yeah
i'm stacking them coins that doesn't
sound remotely cool
nonetheless right in the middle of this
whole thing because of the fact that
hawkman is kind of like okay so like he
doesn't really want to use it for
absolute power maybe lobo really is the
best person to put it you know put this
in the hands up he's exceedingly strong
he's got a healing factor he's not
easily defeated right so maybe he really
is the best choice because he's
essentially superman who's
also like a terrible human being or a
terrible a terrible being out there but
at the same time doesn't want to use it
for absolute power right he's just gonna
hand it over to whoever sent him on this
mission which is probably for a good
cause i don't know i mean i guess
hawkman's kind of assuming
but in the middle of all that they're
suddenly meant by the return of
batlobo who's who's flying this amazing
looking batwing and just
raining down the hell fire on this place
now a portal also ends up opening that
that hawkman created but he doesn't
really know where it goes to
and so instead where he tells hawk or he
tells lobo go through there i'll hold
him off lobos snatches him up and says
nope you're coming with me and when they
pass through the portal they end up
inside gym world
right and so from there lobo ends up
basically using this this device to kind
of recreate reality right
or at least seemingly recreate reality
we're not really given a full-on
explanation here because somehow or
another
we basically end up transitioning from
gym world into
uh into this this you know lobo land and
the only real kind of
transition that we get here is when lobo
kind of opens the box and says like this
is the part i've been waiting for right
so seemingly he basically created like
this whole dimension where everybody
seems to basically be a version of lobo
right like you've got like a lobo
superman story you've got a lobo batman
story you got a lobo wonder woman story
but in the middle of all that while he's
kind of doing all this stuff then
suddenly he's met by the arrival of
brainiac and brainiac of course managed
to escape the confines of uh of perpetua
and justice league number 56. i don't
know if anybody read that
honestly we don't really need you to
understand it we can just say brainiac
was locked away at some
point he basically ended up escaping
what perpetua was thrown was destroyed
done right that's really all you need to
know but he's essentially here
for the purpose of trying to get uh lobo
to hand the device over to
over to him and the idea is that if lex
luthor you know lexus basically told him
that if lex ever
ever ended up going missing to ensure
that lobo handed over the device to
brainiac right now
this is suspicious at best or as mariah
uh maro says
this is sus i am getting terribly off
topic gordon's gonna have gordon's gonna
have a job
sorting all this stuff out trying to
figure out what stays and what goes
but uh in an even what lobo actually
ends up doing is kind of
warping reality to a degree now here's
the funny thing about this this is very
reminiscent of the old captain britain
story when he first encountered madrid
jasper's or
really the second time they fought when
he fought jim jasper's from the maine
marvel universe where he kept snapping
his fingers
and all of reality just kept changing on
a whim like in the blink of an eye
reality just kept changing every single
time he snapped it was something
different and
captain britain was just wildly
outclassed right it was kind of cool
which is i'm hoping we see something
like that during
the ten of swords event from marvel but
um he basically kind of ends up you know
basically poking fun at brainiac makes
him look like
mrs tibbs right his miss tips his fourth
grade teacher but just kind of
goofing off right and making brainiac
look like a bit of a buffoon and not
really taking any of this stuff
seriously but that's when brainiac
actually kind of takes a break away from
the character that we're normally used
to and says look like lobo you have to
pay attention right you are literally a
survivor the last of your kind
the toughest bass ditch in the universe
in your jargon you've survived alone the
odds are beyond
the bounds of viability but you beat
them by being selfish
and then you ask this crazy question
like what's the difference between jam
and jelly and
between yeah between jelly and jam he's
like the sugar content he's like wrong i
can't jelly this gun up your exhaust
words
but he basically like beseeches him and
he says look this is going to be the
biggest
test of your survival skills that you
are going to have to be selfish
your selfishness is your survival so be
selfish with us
right like give me the death metal it's
the only way that we can possibly live
and so what ends up happening is you end
up having in the middle of this kind of
discussion that suddenly
batman lobo pops back up again and
basically starts going on the
going on the offense against lobo this
is 1990s comics guys if this feels
chaotic and insane this was comics in
the 1990s almost universally across the
board it was like every 15 year old
every 15 year old's bedroom right just a
chaotic disorganized
mess that's basically what it was right
that's basically how this this whole
thing was and so because of that with
bat lobo kind of getting the upper hand
to a degree lomo of course having the
ability to control this reality
basically ends up grabbing bat lobo and
just kind of sticking him back down
basically into into lomo land right like
like get a blast lobo land in your face
he's like in you go and basically like
kind of shoves him in there into this
little pocket dimension and kind of
keeps the guy locked away right now
presumably he can escape
at some future point in time but of
course you know lobo ends up restoring
brainiac back to his normal self and
then says like the inflection point
approaches right the moment with when
existence
hangs in the balance the key to
everything is in your blood and so lobo
kinda has this idea okay like he's gonna
pull this wild and crazy stunt we have
no idea what it is but seemingly the
fate of all reality
comes down to the hands of a
death metal rock music
crazy dark version of superman
who's probably one of the coolest dc
characters ever created so with that
being said guys we're going to bring
this video to an end if you are new here
to comments explain make sure you guys
hit the sub button to become part of the
rob corps if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like
and i will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you